ce matin est plus calme aux urgences
après des jours de saturation plus
souvent les véhicules d'urgence restent
bloqués à l'entrée faute de brancards
disponible pour laisser les malades
l'affluence moyenne de 130 personnes par
jour a connu des pics à 176 avec de
sérieuses conséquences
au moment de ma prise de poste j'ai des
patients qui sont là depuis le 24 donc
48 heures du mans doit être une
trentaine ou une quarantaine de moins
qu'un évidemment si à l'extérieur on a
une dizaine d'ambulances et de saab et
de confier qu'ils attendent
on a plus de place donc il faut qu'ils
patientent il faut que les patients
passés au dessus les brocarder des
autres professionnels
ça veut dire que les pompiers ne peuvent
faire partie des pompiers ne veux pas
vous repentir ils sont
bloqués ils sont immobilisés devant ici
attendre d'un accidenté des malades en
insuffisance cardiaque ou respiratoire
beaucoup de personnes âgées dans les
pathologies sont multiples dans ses
couloirs chacun doit pouvoir être
réexaminé toutes les heures et les
soignants l'équipement pour secourir un
malade en urgence vitale mais le temps
il paraît bien trop long à 20 heures
c'est ici j'ai vu je dois être super
spéciale d'ici auctions claudio
j'attends pas ce qu'il fait depuis hier
soir j'ai pas mangé et c'est maintenant
là il me donnait perfusion mais depuis
ceux-ci gabri tic en plus aux urgences
on estime qu'une attentes supérieures à
10 heures devient excessive
c'est qu'on avale tous les services de
soins critiques ont été submergés de
patients en réanimation cardiologie un
afflux que l'on n'explique pas mais
auquel il a fallu remédier malgré un
déficit chronique
le chum a dû recruter une dizaine de
soignants et réouvrir délit oui on vient
de rouvrir 20 lits supplémentaires et
surtout on a réussi à rouvrir quatre
lits d'unités de soins intensifs cardio
c'est un projet sur lequel ont travaillé
mais qui n'avaient pas encore abouti et
finalement la fab ou tir en quelques
heures hier soir avec un gros travail de
toutes les équipes soignantes parent
médicales et administratives et on a
réussi à les ouvrir hier soir ce qui a
permis de gagner un niveau de confort et
de sécurité aux urgences devant cette
crise exceptionnelle et avant l'arrivée
de la grippe l'hôpital invite ceux qui
le peuvent à consulter en priorité leur
médecin ou leur maison de garde pas
d'être convocation les bons secte homme
qui ferait qu' il faudrait parvenir par
vous même globalement appeler le 15 a
vraiment essayé le médecin du qu'est ce
qui va vous dire écoutez là peut-être
qu'il faut aller voir votre médecin
traitant ce n'est pas utile de venir aux
urgences
donc le recours à l'appel du 15 ça va
vraiment permettre dans un premier temps
de dégrisement désengorger puis vous si
vous pensez que a priori c'est pas très
grave mais allez voir votre médecin de
ville hier en effet sur 32 patients
venus spontanément aux urnes
seuls quatre avaient été préalablement
orientée par le garde